- I'll be waiting
late into the night.
Hopefully we'll know
the result that night
'cause the last thing
I think we need is
a case going to the
court over the election
with the deciding vote
being cast by a justice
who was just appointed
by one of the litigants
to the Supreme Court.
(upbeat music)
- All right, we're doing a quick
on the fly interview
today with the legendary
lawyer legal scholar
and one of the last sane
liberals around Alan Dershowitz.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Well, thanks.
It's a pleasure to be on
with another sane liberal.
- There ain't many
left, are there?.
- We have to have our next
meeting in a phone booth.
- There's about, there's
about 10 of us left.
So I just said to
you, before we started
that I'd love to have you back
for a full extended hour long
interview that I normally do.
I appreciate you jumping
in today because of the
Amy Coney Barrett
confirmation yesterday,
just to clean up some
of the legal stuff,
I know we could complain about
what's happened to
the libs all day long,
but let's just talk about
some legal stuff today
and then we'll
pick up and do that
in the next couple of weeks.
So first off, she was
confirmed yesterday.
I suspect, although you
probably don't agree
with perhaps all of her
past judicial decisions
or some of her reasoning
that you think that
her being confirmed
was the right decision.
Is that too much of
a leading question?
- A little bit too much
of a leading question.
If the decision was
going to be made,
it was the right decision.
That is, she was
highly qualified.
She is as qualified
as Merrick Garland,
but Merrick Garland should
have been confirmed as well.
So I object to the process.
I think the Republicans stole
a seat on the Supreme Court
from the Democrats and that
was improper back in 1990,
in 2016, that was wrong.
And they established
a precedent,
which they didn't follow,
namely that if a
nomination comes
within months of an election,
it should be deferred.
But passing that,
I basically agree
with the vote that was made
by the Senator for Alaska.
She said she
opposed the process,
but she didn't
want to take it out
on a highly qualified justice.
So yes, she's highly
qualified, no doubt about that.
- When we get into
the hypocrisy game
of what the Republicans did
just a couple of years ago,
and some of the things that
the Democrats are saying,
there's nobody that's
innocent in that right,
at this point?
- It started with Bork.
We have a verb now
to Bork somebody,
it then moved to abolishing
the cloture and filibuster
first on all judges then
on Supreme Court justices.
And now of course, this
morning already AOC and others
are demanding that
the court be packed.
There's a big op-ed or in
today's New York Times,
a series of op-eds about
how to fix the court.
I mean the only thing broken
about the court today
essentially is that
it is dominated
by conservatives.
I don't think the people
who wrote the op-eds,
most of them would have
tried to fix the court
if the shoe were
on the other foot.
And if it was six to three
in favor of liberals,
they only want to fix it,
because they want their ideology
to dominate on the court.
- So I'm curious back in 2013,
when Harry Reed, you know,
did the nuclear option,
I was a lefty, I
was a big liberal,
I was a Democrat,
the whole thing
and there is video on YouTube
people can find it of me
saying this is a bad move.
It will be used against us.
That's exactly what Mitch
McConnell said back then.
What were you saying?
- Same thing.
Same thing.
Look, I've always taken the view
that I put the institution
of the Supreme Court,
the country before
partisan politics.
That's what got me in
trouble with so many of my
so-called liberal friends
who wouldn't understand a
liberal if they fell over one,
liberal friends who
object to the fact that
I defended the constitution
when the House of
Representatives tried to impeach
President Trump who I voted
against in the 2016 election
on unconstitutional grounds.
I favor the constitution and
institutional support
for the Supreme Court
over any kind of
ideological preference.
- Do you think that
in normal times
and I don't even know how
to define that anymore
that because we'd be talking
more about ACBs qualifications
rather than the process
she strikes me as the
type of person that
maybe 30 years ago let's say,
she probably would have got 70
votes or something like that
do you think that
that's something like
that's fair to say?
- I think 98 votes
is fair to say.
Scalia got 98 votes
and Scalia didn't try to
hide his views at all.
Justice Ginsburg got
many, many, many votes
she didn't try to
hide her views.
The tradition back
in the day was that
you affirm somebody
for the Supreme Court
if they're highly qualified,
that was broken
for the first time
with the Bork nomination.
Bork was extremely qualified,
he was a professor at Yale,
he was Solicitor General,
he was a judge, but he had
extreme right-wing views
and he didn't present
them effectively.
He made statements in
front of the Senate,
which really put a
lot of people off,
including a lot of Republicans.
And so he failed the
confirmation process test
but it turned into
more of a principle.
Look, when you get a
court, a Supreme Court
that doesn't affect the
lives of ordinary people
as the Supreme Court didn't
for the first hundred
years of its existence,
nobody cared who was
on the Supreme Court,
but when the Supreme
court decides
desegregation as it should have,
Roe vs. Wade, gay marriage
people are gonna say, who
are those robed people?
Why don't we get input into
who is put on the court
they're affecting
our daily lives?
So, you know, there's
no free lunch.
If want the Supreme Court
to be de-politicized,
then the Supreme
Court should stay away
from making controversial
divisive decisions.
If they're going to make
controversial decisions
then they're going to
become politicized.
That's what democracy
is all about.
- I'm guessing that
not much can shock you,
but is any of the language
coming out of the
Democrats right now
shocking to you in that
there's basically just a
let's burn it all down
feeling right now.
Not just let's pack the courts
but let's change the
electoral college.
Let's change every
institution that in many ways,
someone like you has
fought for your whole life
to strengthen?
- Yeah, because
they're not interested in
changing the institutions
they're interested
in getting their way.
and whatever it takes
to get their way,
they're prepared to do.
If the shoe were on
the other foot again,
they would be the
strongest defenders
of these various institutions.
But they, you know,
there's an intolerance.
It reflects itself
on campuses today.
Why do we need free speech?
We know the truth.
Why do we need due process?
We know if a woman
accuses a man,
of course the woman's
telling the truth
and the man is guilty.
Why do we need any
of these processes?
We know, we know the truth.
We're endowed with this special
ability to discern truth
and we don't need process,
we don't need speech.
We don't need due process.
We don't need the Supreme Court.
We don't need the
electoral college.
We don't need anything.
Just give us the ability
to rule and dictate
and we'll dictate
in the right way,
said Stalin and Mao,
and many of the students
on college campuses today.
- So I'm curious
with that in mind,
I've been making an argument
and I did not vote for
Trump four years ago,
I voted for Gary Johnson,
but I am going to vote
for Trump this time.
I've been making an
argument that in an odd way,
Trump is defending both
liberalism and conservatism
at this point in that
he's defending conservatism
that's obvious,
the judges and the policies
are fairly conservative
and he's defending
liberalism because
he's basically the last door,
between the lefties just
ramming through everything.
Does that make some
kind of sense to you?
As bizarre as it sounds,
Trump is defending liberalism.
- Unintentionally, he's
defending liberalism
and many conservatives
defend liberalism today
because it's their ox
that's getting gored
by the extreme left.
But remember I'm old
enough, you're not
to remember when it
was the conservatives
who were suppressing
free speech on campus.
I grew up during McCarthyism.
And so, as you said
in the beginning,
there's enough hypocrisy
to go around on both sides.
What we need is a core
of liberal centrist,
conservative centrists
who have to work together
to preserve institutions
without regard to
what the outcome is.
We have to be focused
on process and fairness.
It was Felix Frankfurter
the great justice
who said the history
of liberty is primarily
the history of
process and procedure.
If you get that right,
you're going to lose
the outcome sometimes,
but next time you'll win.
But if you change the process
and eliminate due
process and free speech,
democracy is done.
- Do you think there's
enough of those liberals
of those centrists?
Are there any left?
I mean we can joke
about, you know,
there being about 10 of us,
obviously there are
other, you know,
just good folks out there,
but it seems like
they've lost all power.
I don't see any of
them represented
by the Democrats at the moment.
I mean, where are they?
- Well, I think you're right.
I would have thought
that Joe Biden
would be one of the
last of the liberals,
the centrist liberals.
And I hope maybe he will be,
but he has to
resist the pressure
from the squad and from the
people on the extreme left.
Look we're going to see
a move toward court
packing immediately.
And I know that Joe Biden
doesn't want to pack the court.
And I know he won't
push court packing,
but what if the Senate and the
House passes court packing,
will he veto it?
Does he have the courage
to stand up against his own
party radicals and veto it?
And I think that's
the great question.
And I agree with you.
We need to build the center.
We need to build,
look, I used to have these
great debates with Bill Buckley.
He was a centrist conservative,
I'm a centrist liberal.
You and I can have
these debates,
but I can't have any discussions
with anybody on
Martha's Vineyard.
I can't have discussions with
members of my own family.
They just know the truth,
they want the outcome they want
and anything that stands in
the way of that is fascism.
So I'm now fascist because
I believe in due process
- Hey, you're in good company.
All right.
So we'll obviously
spend a lot more time
talking about that in
a separate interview,
but I just let's dive into
it a little bit more here,
because I think a lot
of people watching this,
especially just, you know
basically a week before
the election, at this point
they're feeling that
these are people who are
lifetime, moderate conservatives
or moderate liberals who now
family members
won't talk to them.
They're being pushed out
of their communities.
When, do you remember as someone
that comes from
the institutions,
that comes from Harvard,
that has been in the
media game for decades
do you remember, was there
a moment that you saw
that you got, whoa, this thing
really is out of control?
- Yeah, I think
it really did come to fruition
with the election
of Donald Trump,
who did reflect a
division in the country.
Look, there's still some
place that people can go to.
They can listen to you
and they can listen to,
I have a podcast now
too called The DerShow.
- The DerShow, not bad.
- I stand for this position,
I always represent kind of
the center liberal position
never take positions on
who should be elected
or who should be appointed,
I talk about the implications
of what's going on in America
and you can get it, you
know, on Spotify or YouTube.
So, you know, listen
to you, listen to me.
- We'll link to it.
- And I do think that
podcasts and things like that
are the wave of the
future, because look,
look, what's going on
today with Hunter Biden.
I I'm a liberal Democrat.
I like Joe Biden.
I don't believe he's corrupt.
But NPR National Public Radio
has now made a policy
that they won't report
on whether or not the
laptop is genuine or not.
I want to know whether
the laptop is genuine.
I want that to influence
my vote one way or another.
Maybe it's not enough to change
my current predisposition
but I'm entitled to know.
And Twitter and Facebook and NPR
are not entitled to keep
that information from me.
- Are you shocked then
at the way that the
media has crumbled
in conjunction with all of this,
because you know I'll
see a lot of times when,
when you go on CNN or
or now you go on Fox
or whatever it might be,
and by the way Fox is the
only one that puts me on,
- CNN has banned
me as well, yeah.
- Oh, they banned you?
Congratulations.
But I see you when
you've gone on there,
I suddenly see people
who you've taught,
people that were your
former colleagues,
people that that you
might've even learned from,
who were suddenly
going off on you
in the worst sort of ways
and usually have
almost no legal backing
behind what they're doing.
And then you get layout
a calm legal precedent,
but they're basically
just calling you names.
And I'm constantly
amazed by that.
- That's true of Jeffrey Toobin,
and you know, Jeffrey
Toobin was my student.
And the point is Jeffrey
Toobin has been wrong
100% of the time
when he's predicted the
outcome of court decisions.
And I've been right, a
hundred percent of the time.
It's not that I'm
smarter than Toobin,
it's that he allows ideology
to influence his prediction.
CNN tells him essentially
how to come out,
'cause he doesn't want
listeners of CNN to be upset
that Supreme Court
may come out in a way
different from his prediction.
And I don't care about that.
And so I get it right
because I don't allow ideology
to skew my predictions.
I follow what Oliver
Wendell Holmes said,
the job of a lawyer
is to predict
in fact what the courts will do,
not what the courts should do.
So Toobin has gotten it wrong,
and I've asked CNN probably
why I've been banned,
I've been asking CNN show
Toobin's predictions,
and then show what happened
so that the listeners and
the viewers can judge him
and decide whether to
listen to what he has to say
then show my predictions
and show what happened.
They, of course won't do that,
'cause people don't care
really about the truth.
They only care
about their truth,
their capital T truth.
- So, I know that you might be
in the legal prediction game
but nobody wants to be in the
political prediction game,
you know, seven days out.
But what do you think?
I mean, what do you think is
going to happen at this point?
- I can't predict,
I'm not in a position
to make that judgment.
I did predict in 2016 in
August that Trump may well win.
And I told that to Hillary
Clinton, who I was supporting,
'cause I had just
come back from Europe
and I had seen the growth of
populism, Brexit, all that.
And I saw a wave
sweeping the world
and I thought it would
sweep America as well.
And I got that right.
But I don't know how
to assess the polls,
the polls show Biden
ahead obviously,
but we know that there's a gap
between polls and Trump voters,
because there are a
lot of Trump voters
who won't tell
pollsters the truth.
So I'll be waiting
late into the night.
Hopefully we'll know
the results that night
'cause the last thing
I think we need is
a case going to the
court over the election
with the deciding vote
being cast by a justice
who was just appointed by
one of the litigants
to the Supreme Court.
So I hope we avoid that.
- Right.
But doesn't it seem
in a bizarre way
that that is sort of almost
where we have to end up now
that the world has
gotten so crazy and that,
you know I keep telling people,
it feels like we're in
the odd stage of democracy
where it's now just
the show must go on.
We just need the
show in an odd way
to keep us all focused on that,
that it would ultimately lead us
to taking this to
the Supreme Court,
because in a bizarre
sense, that's the show.
- Well, if it goes
to the Supreme Court,
I hope that whoever loses
will do what Al Gore did,
and what Richard Nixon did,
and concede defeat and
have peaceful transition.
Let's hope that happens.
I think there's some possibility
the election may be
decided on that night.
If Florida, Pennsylvania,
Ohio, Michigan,
all go for one candidate
that will probably be
the winning candidate.
- All right.
Let me ask you one
other thing for now
and then we will pick this up
in the next couple of weeks.
For the, so I get
that on the left
there's this burn
it down feeling,
and they want to change
all of the norms,
but what I'm also seeing now,
as I've been let's say
more welcomed on the right
is there's a version of that
on the right as well which is,
oh, well the, the
lefties are so bananas
and the institutions have
failed us at such a level
that we also should
burn it all down.
I'm not a full burn it
all down guy, right?
I want to keep some
of those things
for the reasons you
just laid out there.
What would you say
to the conservatives
who now hold that position
especially if Trump
loses who at that point
they're all gonna say, all
right, they wanted to burn it,
well now we'll show
them who's boss?
- Well, I've already commented
on that with Lindsey Graham,
who I liked as a person.
Lindsey Graham said look,
I'm never going to allow a
nomination at the Supreme Court
to come within a
year of an election
and you can use my
words against me.
So they used his
words against him.
And he said, no, no, no, no no,
the rules changed
after what they did
to the prior justice
to Kavanaugh,
and they raised all these
fake issues about, you know,
his 15 year old.
And he said, I'm going to
burn it down basically.
He didn't use the
words burned it down,
but I'm going to
change the rules.
I don't think that's right.
I don't think you fight dirty
politics with dirty politics.
And I hope that if whoever wins
continues to play by the rules,
none of us will gain by a
burning it down mentality
because you know who
they're gonna burn down?
They're gonna burn us down.
We're gonna be the guys
who they burn down.
And if you think you're exempt
from that, forget about it.
Just remember the
French Revolution.
Nobody could get far enough
left to avoid being guillotined.
Even the people who thought
they were leading the
French Revolution,
ended up losing their heads.
When you have violence and riots
and the kinds of lawlessness
that I think both sides
are capable of engaging in,
the losers are our democracy.
So, you know, get ready to lose,
whether you're a
Democrat or Republican
and then prepare
to win next time.
That's the answer.
Don't go to the streets and
don't engage in violence.
And I'm afraid we may
have some violence
following this election.
And that's a great concern.
- Yeah.
Spoken like a true liberal.
And as a guy that's a
talking head for a living,
I'd like to keep my head
attached to my body.
We shall see, we shall see.
All right, The DerShow is
available on iTunes and YouTube
and Spotify and everywhere
that you can get podcasts
and we'll get you back
after the election.
And we'll unpack.
- That would be wonderful.
I had a great time
talking to you.
You're a terrific host.
- Thanks Alan.
I appreciate it.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversation about law,
instead of the nonstop
yelling to get everywhere else
check out our law playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.